it's being hailed as a pivotal moment
for europe
eu leaders agreement on a 750 billion
euro
corona recovery package after a marathon
four nights of heated negotiations the
leaders struck a deal to provide 390
billion euros in grants
and another 360 in low-interest loans to
member states
hardest hit by the pandemic it'll be
financed by collective
borrowing a paradigm shift for the eu
will the deal hold the eurozone together
or have member states simply
papered over the cracks in europe's
foundations
corona recovery deal can the eu rebound
that's our title
[Music]
[Music]
and it's a pleasure to welcome our
guests eric kishbaum is an american
journalist who has written for the los
angeles time amongst other media outlets
and he says the summit exposed once
again how much
disunity there is in the european union
and we're very glad to have with us
paveltokov tovoski
he took excuse me he is a polish
economist and senior associate
at the german institute for
international and security affairs
he says we must reform the member states
now
or we'll face the same problems again
with less time and fewer instruments
and great to have with us once again
casting gamalin she is deputy
editor-in-chief of the parliamentary
bureau of the german
newspaper suit deutsche saitung and she
says
the deal is far from perfect but it is a
signal that multilateralism
is still alive
and let me start with you kesten and ask
for your take
on the big picture there are a lot of
superlatives being thrown around
here a historic a breakthrough
uh chancellor mackel saying uh it's a
huge step
for the eu would you agree with all that
i would say yes it's a huge step forward
for germany and also for the eu because
germany basically changed mind
in giving out grants
instead of loans but i would i'm not
with all these people that are saying
it's now a historic moment because i
think history
is written uh from the past
from the future so historians will have
to judge whether that was historic
for for the moment now it is big pavel
how would you see it
as an economist i see it as the most
significant moment in the european
economic integration since the creation
of the euro
because so far we had financial
assistance which consisted of loans
now we have grants and and
those grants are quite substantial is
something around 750 billion of euros
however from the economic perspective
for now i think that the most important
is what the ecb is doing how
long be able to stabilize the bond
market thank you very much and we'll
come back
to that point a little bit later on eric
how would you come down on this historic
or
less so what we just heard from pavel
indicates it is indeed a very very big
step how do you see it well the
mutualization of debt for the first time
is a big big step it's something that
was long overdue the eu could have done
this a decade ago
the eurozone crisis might not have been
as severe as it was but on the other
hand five days and five nights of
negotiations for this deal that could
have been done in a day is a bit of a
farce
and it just showed the eu the eu is far
from united united and with the problems
facing the eu and facing the world
it's not really um making the mary fit
for the future when they take five days
to get a decision like this done if i
may say that i mean
your eu is is united otherwise you would
not have a deal
i mean i agree with you it was very very
difficult and
five days and four nights to negotiate
it's more at the end but i'm sorry by
the end there's a deal
with a small stage and other countries
in the world they never
manage to make a deal and here's a deal
made by 27
national member states one last big
picture
question to you pavel before we take a
look at some of the details of this deal
it was a compromise as both essentially
have
have conceded with significant
trade-offs made
by pretty much all interested parties
the question is whether the result
justifies those concessions
of course this justifies the concessions
and we have to bear in mind that we have
in the in the eu 27 different member
states with different size with
different economic systems
and for some of these member states it's
really a huge step forward like for the
netherlands or for sweden
to actually to guarantee the common debt
to come come on the
common transfers would go to the south
so this is a huge step forward which
nobody in those countries expected and
the politicians of these countries will
have to face
criticism at home so let us in fact now
take a
closer look at the corona recovery
package
and those north-south divisions that it
provoked
it was clear there'd be a fight over the
750 billion euro recovery fund
and it exposed deep reps within the eu
countries like italy and spain who've
been especially hard hit by the corona
pandemic
worked hard to counter resistance from
countries like the netherlands and
austria
that would prefer to save money after
marathon negotiations they reduced the
amount of direct aid
to 390 billion for the first time
the eu will issue common debt despite
all the haggling the current president
of the eu council was pleased
this i think this is a clear signal that
goes
beyond europe that this very special
structure this very special entity
the european union consists of 27 member
states that can act together despite
their very different backgrounds
and that have proven they have the
capacity to act
that is a good sign
but what is the deal actually worth
eric you talked in your opening
statement about the disunity exposed
by this deal in fact there were moments
where it looked as you said over the
course of five days as if there might
not
be a deal would you say those
north-south
divisions will leave lasting scars
absolutely it's not just north-south now
it's east-west we saw small groups of
eastern european countries able to
blackmail their interests
we saw the small frugals able to force
their interest through
the eu used to be led by france and
germany kind of leading the way and now
people are getting away with in the in
the wake of britain leaving the eu
smaller countries are coming up with
their special interests
and it's a scary moment if you think the
world the way the world's going with
china and the united states these big
power blocks
and the eu here in the middle with 27
countries haggling over small little
details
is the eu going to be able to compete
with these big countries in the world of
the future
i'm sorry but i it's totally different
actually what i see this
is uh the proof that liberalism is still
alive
i mean 27 member states make a deal and
it's sure
it took a very long time and we still
have this division between
south and uh north and east and west
sure but
i mean the special situation here was
that normally until march
germany was in one line with the
netherlands austria and these little
countries
that say they are frugal so actually
germany was the leader in saying
austerity
and after that crisis suddenly there was
a change in german politics
and a big change so germany stepped away
from australia
and went to the to to france again
and then they had this strong french
german motor
that basically came out with this
proposal to
deliver 500 billion in grants
and and this was a big change i mean
we were in fact told by the german press
at least that the chancellor seemed to
be
favoring the colors of the trico
tricolora the french red white and blue
would you say that there is a lasting
change here to the balance of power in
europe
in part due to chancellor mackel's
decision to
go to the other side i mean we see
clearly that what it means that
great britain is not here anymore
because great britain was also balancing
as a big power the european decisions
and i would not be sure that there's a
permanent shift now
from germany uh uh to the to the side of
the southern countries or the southern
big countries but on
at the other at the other side i would
say there is no alternative really
what should germany do i mean there are
four big uh
um economies now left over in in the
european union and they have to stay
together otherwise the european internal
market which is by the way the biggest
in the
in the world will break away
let's talk a bit about some of the
economic details
of the situation in which europe finds
itself
before the countries went into the
summit the leaders went into the summit
there was a lot of talk about the
eurozone
survival being at stake largely because
of the divergence between
northern and southern economies if we
look
at the current numbers germany the
netherlands
it looks like they're going to see an
economic contraction this year of around
6.5
spain and italy are more are almost
double that
so will this deal now
close that gap the head of the european
central bank has said that
gap is putting the very survival of the
euro
in danger do you think the deal will get
money to those southern countries in
such a way and quickly enough
that it can close that divergence i
fully agree that the divergence the
diversity
in nothing not only in the euro area but
especially the single market
is a very very bad thing and
what changed the minds of the leader at
the summit i think
it was the threat about the
integrity of the single market that some
countries after corona crisis would be
actually
developing badly and then the populists
in those countries can actually change
the
political lines of those countries so
the economic divergence can cause social
divergence and
social the diversion can have a very
negative impact on the
political unity of the union and i think
that all the leaders understood it very
well
and that's why uh we have this decision
um at the summit
so let me ask you this eric the dire
economic prospects that are facing those
southern european
countries are not only of course due to
corona there were macroeconomic
weaknesses in spain and italy and
elsewhere that preceded
the crisis the krugel 4 were determined
to make sure
that this recovery package
essentially helps to remedy those
macroeconomic weaknesses by imposing
what's called conditionality
do you think that we will see true
reform on the basis of this deal
i think they have to and i think um the
reason germany switched sides and was
suddenly in favor of collectivizing the
debt
is because merkel realized that the
corona is a one-time thing it's an
exceptional circumstance
the problems with corona is not only
because of the economic problems they're
having before
and she also realized piling more debt
on these southern states was going to
drive them into into really dire straits
so this is a one-off perhaps we'll see
but i think merkel also realized it was
the right thing to do
and there will be controls now the
netherlands pushed this through that
they will control with the
conditionality to make sure
the money is being spent on things to
help mitigate the impact of corona so
if you're a frugal person you have to
say well okay we'll see how this works
um not a bad deal could have been better
but at least this will go for corona
related issues
next year america will be gone it's
unlikely another conservative chancellor
will do this again so i i do think this
is a one-off
this will be limited to the corona
crisis and hopefully the money will go
to the right places in these countries
to help them
overcome the corona crisis kirsten one
of the points of criticism
uh for some observers it's what is what
they're calling the governance
architecture of this deal meaning those
conditions that i mentioned
that are supposed to ensure reform in
the southern
european economies that they're going to
be essentially overseen
by other eu leaders not by the
institutions in brussels
but by the european council itself isn't
that a recipe for ongoing divisions and
delays
ah sure it is i must say because it is
actually unpossible that a different
member states can tell
the parliament in a different country
what kind of budget they have to do and
what kind of reforms they have to
do i mean in the european union all
member states are sovereign
national states and it's actually
unpossible that another sovereign state
can
tell you what to do on the other hand
and i think
that that was the reason why they had to
find a compromise
i mean taxpayers from all from all
national states are guaranteeing
these grants and so the debt is a common
debt in a way
and that means also the german taxpayers
or the or the taxpayers from the
netherlands
want to make sure that the money that is
now on the table
will be spent on the right way and i
think it there is also a common
understanding
that there has to be a kind of control
pavel
your opening statement referred to the
need for reform
in member states do you think this
conditionality is going to do the job
i don't know it's difficult to say
because we will have an
extreme time pressure the member states
will have to prepare
programs to get the money in a very
short time and those programs will be
assessed by the european commission
and then by the member states so it's uh
difficult to say what kind of quality of
this project will be
and where the money will be spent and
knowing the institutional deficiencies
in southern european countries that
it's going to be a challenge let me come
to a different point
all of you have mentioned the provisions
for common debt basically the idea is
that much of this recovery package will
be financed
by borrowing on the financial markets by
the european union
commission now when that proposal was
first made
eric uh olaf schultz the german finance
minister referred to
it or essentially made the analogy to
the so-called hamiltonian moment
for you and me as americans uh i think a
lot of us know about that moment because
of the musical hamilton but let me just
remind our
visitors it was the moment in 1790 when
the very first treasury secretary
of the united states persuaded those
nascent american states still very young
to accept
common debt that essentially
was the first step toward u.s fiscal
integration which has made the u.s an
absolute powerhouse also on
international financial markets
is the same thing happening here um no
this is a very very small step in the
right direction but a small step and way
too late
um that was 1790 and the united states
was able to flourish and blossom because
of
that promise and the promise to pay back
all that debt the united states has
always paid back
on on the on the money it's borrowed and
that's why the u.s is such a great
creditor
and the eu has been hemming and hawing
about this question for two decades now
the euro has been around for 20 years
but there's no collective debt and
that's the fundamental flaw the
fundamental weakness of the euro
and they knew about this 10 years ago
when the eurozone crisis flared out
they've been talking about it ever since
and now they're taking a small very baby
step towards
the hamiltonian moment hopefully it will
be it will be something that will bring
um bring the give the euro some some
power but i'm i'm skeptical i doubt it's
more than a one-off cast in the
hamiltonian moment
if i could just say this the hamiltonian
moment wasn't actually a moment it was a
process of fiscal integration that
went on over decades and is still not
finished in the u.s
yeah and i think the first step was
introducing of the euro and now we have
the second step
of starting with a common adapt and i
think
i think we have to take a decision or
europe has to take the decision
whether they will continue in that way
and also the next chancellor wherever
who whoever that will be uh perhaps it's
a green one you'll never know her
but we have to decide do we go straight
on this way or
do we stop and then we have to give up
also this common currency
i think we are here at the point where
they have to take a decision which
which way paul can i get you to weigh in
very quickly on the common edition
i would like to remind this is not the
first time that the eu is issuing that
issue it was the eu was issuing debt for
the last 10 years but
it's going to be the biggest step yeah
it was only in small amounts and it was
only for loans
and now it would be for the first time
that is issuing
debt for grants so this is a this is new
and
the question is if uh we are the
conditionality of that will be
strong enough uh for the leaders in
southern europe to actually use this
money properly
because for some of them it would be the
last chance to reform the countries
there will be
no second chance so a lot of writing on
this
and a lot riding on another aspect
of the deal as well it wasn't only
north-south tensions over frugality that
nearly torpedoed the negotiations at the
summit
so too did east-west divisions over
linking eu funding
to recipient countries compliance with
european principles on democratic values
and rule of law
here's more the text that has been
agreed on the rule of law
has improved it's a very clear in the
document a very clear commitment
to the rule of law and a very clear
commitment to the protection
of the financial interests of the union
any attempt which tried to make a
connection between rule and law
and budget was
was hacked was successfully
rejected
[Music]
so cast in pretty contradictory
assertions there uh
lion and victor orban who's right
yeah basically everybody did win because
we have a close now in this
in the statement of of the summit that
says okay we have to put
the paying to the role of law to
fulfilling the rule of law
but there is a little second sentence
which says okay but the member states
have to decide
so basically also frontal line is right
by saying okay we dedicated
our money to to guarantee
that the the states which will get the
money will
be in line with the rule of law but
there's also
some truth to orban which is saying we
rejected it
but he can veto such a decision
let me ask you pavel again your opening
state statement talked about
the need for reform and also your
concern about whether
there are enough instruments in the
toolbox of the eu to compel
reform now your own country poland has
been
under ongoing pressure from brussels for
its effort to
undermine the independence of the
judiciary will this deal
change anything i don't think that it
will
change anything unfortunately the eu has
no
real instruments to influence countries
like poland and hungary
and the eu budget eu finances are
unfortunately a weak instrument to do
that
in the last eu budget in the last
financial framework we had similar
instruments so-called macroeconomic
conditionality to influence the economic
policies of member states and it proved
to be actually toothless
so i don't think that during the next
three years the eu will be managed to
stop
uh yellows of karczynski to further
destroy the
polish institutions let me just follow
up on that
there are also currently legal
proceedings
ongoing with european union member
countries that have not
uh complied with eu rule of law
and those are not yet resolved
taken together if they were resolved
against the countries
if they were found not to be in
compliance together with what is at
least
now a principle of linkage
in this deal could that start to change
things
i don't think the current government in
poland is
really making two step forwards on the
way to
um destruction of the rule of law and
one step backwards
when the pressure from the brussels is
really high and now
um again the president of the ruling
party won the elections and
kachinsky has a full powering poland and
he can do everything he wants with the
judiciary
and now for that next step will be the
polish independent media
eric you haven't been overly optimistic
so far about the agreement
would you differ without analysis or do
you also think this is toothless
i think it's a nightmare that these
eastern european countries were able to
water down things and and countries that
are trampling on
on the status rule of law limiting press
freedom
limiting judicial freedom it's it's it's
a worrisome
development and they got away with it
and you know how can everybody there be
a winner how can all 27 countries walk
away as winners
i don't get it there's always a winner
and there's a loser but they all claim
to be winners of the eu summit
if i bring if i can a very easy example
if you imagine 27 families are living in
a big house with 27 apartments
so everybody that owns an apartment has
its own problems
so the eastern europeans have i don't
know problems with the window
on top they have problems with the sun
and the balconies and on the basements
they have also
problems i don't know with the water
coming in and everybody's saying oh this
is my biggest problem here and so at the
end the 27
owners of these apartments in the big
european house agreed
on a plan which is dedicated to fix the
whole house
whether it will happen or not is a
different question but this plan
basically helps to fix the house and in
that way everybody can be a winner
because everybody everybody can still
live in that house but one of those
owners can block the whole
thing and that's the whole weekend oh
but so far so far not because everybody
of the seven signed disagreement after
five days a night let me let me ask you
for me as a lawyer
this is a vague provision i grant that
uh on the conditionality
relating to rule of law yet it is now in
a document
yeah that will have a certain legal
value going forward
does that not establish some kind of
lever that could perhaps be strengthened
over time
could be could be that exactly that will
happen
but we have to see that i mean i think
that was the best deal they could get
out
it's not ideal far from
ideal but it is a deal and perhaps it
will help and perhaps
if the water is draining in they will do
more
pablo this deal still has to be approved
by the eu parliament
do you think we'll see any changes i
don't think the donation changes because
uh the polish government needs
desperately this money the situation
that the public finances is very bad
so uh they will be very happy to receive
this 160 billion euros
so very briefly i want to come back to
our title
uh the question was will this help the
eu rebound
casting gave us the great analogy of the
common house would you say the
foundations are at all stronger do this
this deal
yeah the collectivization of debt was a
big step forward and that's
something to cheer about they still have
to work on the household
i'm not gonna let you get out of the
question all together is the eu more
resilient
i mean now the result of that summit is
that the eu is still existing
that is to yourself whether it's more
resilient we will see
from the economic perspective is
definitely more resilient we have the
ecb intervention we have
still huge national package now this on
the top the eu package which make
makes the possible economic crisis or
debt crisis not really
probable it's often said by
eu leaders that it's time for europe to
speak with a common voice and to play a
stronger role in the world
does this deal help it at all to do that
well when the eu is getting economically
stronger then definitely
it will be have a stronger voice and
also the issuing common debt will also
increase the international
importance of the common currency so
it's also very crucial for the eu
thank you very much to all of you for
being with us for this discussion
thanks to all of you out there for
tuning in see you soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you